yo key Glock check me out on a booklet
care podcast
bootleg cat podcast special guests in
here key Glock yo what's up my boy
welcome
my guy's fresh off and making a
extravagant necklace purchase yeah this
is your brand new chain you have here so
this thing right here is uh a lot
yeah you showed me how much it costs
this is just say a lot
uh there must be some real special uh
diamonds like what are those like
Flawless or VBS or what's
the emeralds in the background
and Rounds Around The Border but and
then you got the long lived off on the
back and the picture of dolphin yeah
yeah that's Fire Man there it is
yeah uh new five pack you just dropped
hey man you've been active Bro you've
been on this [ __ ] man I got to yeah you
gotta turn it up bro
um obviously yesterday was a tough day
one year since we lost golf
it's crazy because I was in Las Vegas
last year when he passed
and I was in Las Vegas again this year
and it's like it's crazy how how are you
feeling man A year later
I know China
I can't just get over the feeling like
it is what it is it stuck with me but
I'll be all right yeah yeah yeah I'm
glad we're getting an album from Dolph
too because that song that dropped is
crazy my favorite song about was that
song
um one that like because you know
sometimes when people pass like
you know I know Dolph was habitually in
the studio so I know there's not a
shortage of music but that was a record
that you had heard way before like when
you cut it yeah yeah
way way before yeah that's why when I
heard now like she he talking about in
his like
damn bro I always knew it's like Eerie
just just I always knew 100 man
do you feel like um because I feel like
golf was somebody who got his flowers
but I feel like
you know he was kind of always like the
underrated like Giant in the game and
and after he passed I feel like it sucks
because the same type of thing happened
with Nipsey where I feel like after
Nipsey died people finally really
appreciated him did you feel like that's
kind of what happened with Dolph where
you saw like
just there was just all of a sudden
everybody was a young dolphin you know
what I'm saying
there's just a normal thing when when
death occurs just like
I ain't gonna say it's wrong to show
love but you know if it ain't genuine
why do it like if it ain't real like you
know what I'm saying everybody know
like I know like you know
[ __ ] didn't [ __ ] with bro like
that you know what I'm saying and me
either but we always we're gonna be
ourselves no matter what and we gonna
show up and show out and stand out fast
yeah I feel like the paper route way has
always just kind of been like you guys
are very much I mean obviously it's
always been an independent thing but
like I feel like you guys are are kind
of like outside of like you know people
do the industry [ __ ] they play the
industry games and I feel like dolphin
yourself
you guys have always just kind of been
on your own Island and like whoever
wants to come [ __ ] with us we're over
here but we ain't chasing nobody down
type [ __ ] and why Chase it yeah I chase
100 man
um you dropped the uh 5l
um is this a warm-up for an album
oh yeah they're gonna have to deal with
me a lot next year yeah I'll let you
know now yeah how much music are you
sitting on
unlimited I record every day every day
no I can't even put a number on the
amount of songs I got so for you it's
like
it's almost like you're recording
because you love to do it yeah I like
recording I like talking [ __ ] I like
standing on my word if you record every
day the chances of everything coming out
are probably slim right
I just know what people like to hear I'm
saying like is it like almost like
practice too like you know what I might
record today I ain't even feeling it
today but I'm gonna get in and just see
what happens just to kind of get my
shots up one thing I don't do I Don't
Force It I Don't Force I Don't Force It
yeah
nothing like
like I just let it happen
what is uh what's your writing process
you punch in are you writing stuff down
or I put I punch in yeah without
punching like
I came I came I came right like I can
write hold on let me say that before
they take this [ __ ] right I can count I
can spill all this [ __ ] hold up but yeah
like like with songs like I look at it
like art I can't just
write it down on the paper because I'm
gonna I'm gonna say it a certain way
right other than me just going in there
and freestyle off the top of my head
punching in it's like I got a blank
sheet of paper I got a blank canvas I'm
just gonna you know what I'm saying I'm
gonna just go for what I know rather
than having a a book with pictures I
already made you know what I'm saying
plus the Beats got to speak to you right
it's like what you sure if you play the
beat the beat is like a feature that's
how I look at it hey your beat selection
has been it's always been crazy yeah
yeah your ear for Beats is special it's
one of the best in the game what do you
attribute that to
you all right my grandma
um my grandmother yeah you're beat yo
you got it here for Beats like I feel
like you can a r some like some other
people you might help them out no for
sure I know I can yeah because I feel
like we always hear somebody like damn
like like yourself Rick Ross has also
got a crazy ear for Beats
um
but yeah salute to you for right because
I mean that's one thing your production
ain't never [ __ ] slacking I don't
know do you like have like a crew that
you're always [ __ ] with in terms of
the beats are you always looking for new
beats like
ain't gonna lie you know it's like I
don't just too much care about the names
like you got this [ __ ] and it's right
here in front of me like
I'm gonna off on the road with it like
one thing with me like
I don't like I don't like people to send
me beats um
I'm more of a Hands-On person like I'd
rather you be in the studio with me you
ain't got to make the beat right there
but I'd rather you just
go through your [ __ ] right there with me
like you know what I'm saying and then
if you like something they can pull up
the the stems and take [ __ ] out of it I
like this Loop but I don't like the
drums I don't did that a lot with
probably half of my songs I put out I
[ __ ] with the Beats yo do you have a
copy of the John Moran rookie card that
you end offer in the background of yeah
uh
we got covered um a couple of fans gave
me that shit's fire yeah if you just
think back like first of all shout out
to John Moran who's
um
one of my he's probably my favorite
player to watch in the league right now
yeah
um but nah that rookie card is wild
yeah super crazy uh I saw uh well you're
obviously a huge Grizzlies fan you guys
are very good right now how does that
feel because the Grizzlies for a little
bit there was rough
after like Marc Gasol and every and Mike
Conley Jr left there was a few rough
years which is how y'all got John Moran
he was the number two overall pick
we wanted the bottom though no I mean
but I mean but you're right you know
okay yeah yeah but now now [ __ ] is lit
no it's up it's up for sure are you
friends with any of the guys
yeah I [ __ ] with the whole team yeah I'm
[ __ ] the whole team even if they
don't know I [ __ ] with them like if you
hung out with John Moran oh hey I don't
hang with no basketball players
um
I don't do that why not because my
lifestyle
lifestyle dead too but I don't I don't
want to be the reason for it either so
hey that's real I'd rather I come hoop
with you I don't want you to come to the
studio around me when I'm smoking and
drinking yeah like me
most rappers are the opposite
they just want to hang out with I mean
it's the other way around too though I
don't like people because rappers want
to hang out with basketball players but
the basketball players would be at the
studio with the rappers you see James
Harden [ __ ] uh you know pretty much
damn a r and a damn little baby album
he's in the studio so much
it's crazy
yeah no that's that's smart though
because I feel like you kind of you know
you gotta ain't gonna say like ain't
nothing wrong with it this just ain't
it's just not me I like hanging with who
I hang with 100 man yeah ain't nothing
against no athletes none though
um what for you
how do you decide what comes out if you
have so much music
like do you make do you like say cool I
know I want to do a five song EP
I made these songs with that in mind or
do you just you just open the folder and
just grab from the [ __ ] that you've been
recording like how do you how do you
pick like what drops like it worked both
ways really I lit I let my team pick I
let my like I did my game pick because
it's like like they it's like I look at
them like
not like actual fans but like they my
boys like they gonna let me know if my
[ __ ] hard or not like Dang Dang or
sugarcoat it so I'd rather let them you
know what I'm saying like
pick the songs because they just their
main audience to my music like you know
what I'm saying they hate around other
people that listen to other people that
listen to other people so they know
where to work and wouldn't what won't
work you know what I'm saying so yeah
but other than that sometimes if it's
just some songs I just just like
personally just like that I just feel
like I just gotta put the message out
there I just you know what I'm saying
put it under my damn self but other than
it I let them I let them pick them yeah
I feel like you've been like coming into
your own as a superstar man I saw I was
at rolling loud in the crowd when you
performed so they were [ __ ] you
didn't tell me that they was bro they
were I was with this lady I have I have
it on video do you remember the lady she
was there she was dressed like a white
lady bro like 30 years old with her man
dressed like a fairy and I was
interviewing people in the crowd and I
was like who are you here to see she
said I'm only here to see key Glock I'm
the key Glock fairy
and I was like what the [ __ ]
and then she had her husband was her
husband and then I was like uh oh this
is your husband and and he was like yeah
we're here to see key Glock and then you
know she was dressed super [ __ ] crazy
like uh you know like like a EDM fairy
and uh they were swing they were
swingers though straight up so she was
like uh she was I guess her husband
is a
you know what a cuck is
her husband was telling us it's all on
camera her husband likes to watch other
dudes oh [ __ ] his girl
I know where the story going trust me
so if you ever see the key Glock fairy
just know it's up for grabs
I ain't gonna get him yeah you got a
while I mean it's just dope to see man
because I even think like back to like
the last time I saw you and Dolph live
was the Dumb and Dumber tour you guys
sold out
um
with that theater in the will turn yeah
I don't be remembering but it was
special bro like that that's all right
man I feel like that tour was so so
Monumental and you're all right for you
too because I feel like that was a a lot
of people's first time being able to see
you live you're like yeah what was like
uh give me a story from that tour man
because I mean that tour is historical
at this point you know really
it's like I ain't allowed with my ass
out there too it's like I had my own set
but then again I had a set that we had
to do together so it's like I was I was
tired I was exhausted but that [ __ ] was
all worth it yeah yeah yeah yeah yeah
yeah yeah yeah because you were
performing that Dolph did his set and
then you came back out together yeah
yeah but even like off the stage like we
we just did so much [ __ ] just you know
what I'm saying just everyday [ __ ] like
what what would what would uh be
something that you and Dolph would do on
a day off on tour
uh
gamble gamble yeah but like we gamble
within each other dice no we don't even
we don't even play with dice like Pooh
oh ping pong card yeah are you good at
ping pong yeah I'm all right I ain't the
best but I I'll keep your head I don't
know I know that's true
I'd be willing to bet something don't
let us get above like a ping-pong table
in here I got that spin I see I I got
somebody for you for sure yeah I don't
want to play you and her PJ I'm playing
you nah nah
uh I got somebody going to speed for me
hey we got to stop the interview real
quick you already know man our partners
in my bookie they be holding me down
when it comes to all the money I'll be
making on gambling on these
[ __ ] Sports man that's right
they're your sports betting Haven all
right and it is Thanksgiving week big
games coming up uh yo we got the uh
Cowboys obviously playing the Giants
Vikings versus the Patriots Bills vs
Lions I think the bills are going to
absolutely
destroy the Lions uh actually you know
you could put together a nice little
three team parlay on Thanksgiving so
while you're watching turkey you can
watch some football and you can win some
[ __ ] money all right but this is the
most important part when you go to my
bookie go to my bookie right now
mybookie.ag
sign up for a new account use the promo
code bootleg
and guess what they will match your
first deposit up to a thousand dollars
so let's say Thanksgiving you're like
you know what I'm trying to get in on
some of this action that's cool sign up
in my bookie put in two three hundred
dollars they're gonna give you another
two or three hundred dollars of free
money to gamble with if you use the
promo code bootleg all right mybookie.ag
head over there right now sign up for an
account so much to gamble on right now
we got NFL we got NBA baseball's over
baseball's trash who gives a [ __ ] NFL
NBA and I think hockey's going on
college football's going on college
basketball is going on what are we
[ __ ] doing let's get this money
mybookie.ag go sign up use the promo
code bootleg right now and they will
match your first deposit up to a
thousand dollars let's get back to the
interview yo what has been um this year
their the Grammy nomination just came
out what's what's your favorite album of
the year that's not your own music
that's
non-p p r e [ __ ] that you could be like
I like the the hang on I don't even know
who nominated bro no I'm saying just in
general this year what's like one of
your favorite items that's that's
dropped this year
quiet
then comes to mind
like real talk
um you don't listen to a lot of people
I'll be out of sight bro yeah what do
you listen to
like if you're in the car and you're not
listening to your own [ __ ] you're
listening to podcasts you're listening
to [ __ ] James Brown like what are you
doing golf right
cheeky Dolby
future
that's the most Memphis way let someone
say future
yeah a little part drip
uh glockberry
Jay fizzle Snoop bands
paper out woo shout out to baby money
too baby money is fire as well in Canada
money
uh let's um
so when you're because I gotta say the
first couple of times you know it's
crazy I gotta share this story
the last time I talked to Dolph was like
three days before he died me and him
were on the phone
and I was
I think your album was out or was coming
out around that time it was funny yeah
so he he called me and he was like yo I
gotta get Glock up there and you and I
have done interviews before but I feel
like
you weren't like out of your shell yet
and I told that to Dolph I was like hey
you want to do I went with all this [ __ ]
right so I told I told him I said look
man you gotta talk to Glock because he
can't just be sitting in these
interviews not talking and [ __ ] because
we have interviews that were terrible
but I love you guys but this is how I am
like it ain't against nobody or nothing
like it ain't against the platform
nothing that's just how I am I'm just no
no for sure but I feel like you I feel
like now you're like I feel like you're
out of your shell a little bit you're
more comfortable because I feel like you
know like you like I I know you know
yeah [ __ ] with you that's fair this is
all yeah yeah that's fair yeah yeah
um you don't we were talking earlier
obviously you're smoking you don't if
you ever [ __ ] with the shrooms
I'm really scared but I want to but I'm
gonna do it I'm gonna do it what are you
scared of
I don't wanna I don't want to see the
wrong thing or think I see the wrong
thing you'll never see the wrong thing
now the thing you see everybody need to
see
you might not like what you see but you
need to see it
mushrooms like psychedelics they'll like
they'll give you what you like with what
you need even if you don't know that you
need it does that make sense
they can be scary yeah you know what's
scary is have you ever heard of DMT what
about it have you heard of it oh no
that's [ __ ] crazy you smoke DMT you
go away for 15 minutes
it's like a t-a-c-o not that DMT should
as well
can you do it I don't even drink liquor
wine I don't drink [ __ ] but
codeine marijuana coding the marijuana
pills close up do you feel like
um
do you feel like you're addicted to
codeine because that's a hard thing I
feel like I know it oh that's fair
have you ever tried to stop and like you
go through withdrawals and [ __ ]
why I try to stop when I know I'm gonna
go back I just keep this [ __ ] real with
myself
it ain't like got a hold of me or
nothing but I mean yeah you don't like
what I like you're also not like uh you
know there's people who do lean and you
can tell because they're [ __ ] they
look pregnant you're at least still in
good shape you know yeah I know I take
care of myself yeah that lean got some
[ __ ] man
that [ __ ] is wild
all my homies who sibling they might be
[ __ ] legit in shape everywhere but
that belly that [ __ ] is
that [ __ ] is serious man I'm still
active I
ain't gonna let it get like that I ain't
gonna sit is it is it still is it still
hard to like get a
uh the uh actual activist or is it man
if a [ __ ] say they drink and act they
lying cause that shit's like gone right
[ __ ] being gone that's what I'm saying
yeah
yeah if you buy some activists you
better [ __ ] die or something they're
gonna die yeah he said you gonna die
you're gonna die drinking a fake [ __ ]
trying to be cool that's crazy for real
dude you so speaking of fake [ __ ] you
showed me how much you spend on the
Chain did you ever just consider at any
point in life just saying I'm a I'm
gonna buy the fake version of this
because No One's Gonna question that
it's fake because I'm key Glock
and then save the money
I can't do that to myself
because I was in a I'm a field I'm gonna
feel Lane yeah so I was in uh I was in
New York City and uh there's this guy
selling uh Rolexes on the street right
[Music]
so we're looking at them and uh I bought
one
yeah so if you guys ever see me wearing
Rolex just know I got it off a [ __ ]
Chinese man
I just got it because my boy got one and
he was like I give you two for whatever
I was like whatever you know whatever
you know so no don't even get your
silver but I don't give a [ __ ] you know
what my name is bootleg Kev for a reason
she
when is uh when is the full full-length
body of work coming
early nature early next year early next
year like early Nation when is the Dolph
album dropping
I just saw the uh the artwork that that
the thing that dropped is the artwork
for the album right the picture or no
that's just for the single okay okay
okay yeah yeah the dog the album is on
the way he's going away I can't give you
I can't you're on it maybe you should be
on it it should be yeah shouldn't maybe
not was there um any sessions for uh the
uh part three of Dumb and Dumber that
were recorded like was that ever
something that you guys were gonna do
it's already done really
so there's a whole joint album already
done before he passed you guys already
had that [ __ ] got a lot of music wow
so that's going to come out too
um no Dumb and Dumber three no wow
well you just you just confirmed that so
confirmation alert no I did Dumb and
Dumber three coming soon no you prefer
diet
he did say you're not gonna be able to
do much without seeing my name next year
yeah
why not you know I don't think I ain't
gonna do no part three to nothing but
I'm just gonna spoil it right quick hmm
I know part threes
why not
a trio feels complete
yeah
but the way I do do [ __ ] is really one
and done but sometimes I'll be extra
right I'm like
press a little harder and hit you with a
second one but
I think Point proven hey uh what do you
think has been the difference the last
five or six years because I feel like
Memphis as a whole
is like at the Forefront of hip-hop now
um and I feel like it was always there
and you guys were always very
influential on like what was happening
in Atlanta
um even like guys like Drake like uh but
in terms of like
Memphis is kind of like the city in rap
now
um
what what like why do you think it's
fine it's finally y'all's time I guess
like and the rest of the industry is
obviously now everyone's signing people
from Memphis everyone's going to Memphis
like it's it's kind of crazy where you
guys are kind of like The Underdogs for
so long and now you guys are on top
foreign
and you guys obviously had a lot to do
with that you know
hey I love you asked me it started with
me hmm
yeah yeah
that's some real [ __ ] yeah
yeah I gave everybody like I ain't gonna
say I made every like all the everybody
my age and younger rap but I gave them
the confidence to go ahead and you know
what I'm saying I gave them
a little bit more boost to that ego too
you know what I'm saying be like oh yeah
glocking dude I know I for sure can you
know what I'm saying so that's really
what it was if you asked me what was the
um for you how did how did uh you and
Dolph end up linking up like and how did
you end up signing and because like were
you always trying to be a rapper or did
it just kind of happen like
nah bro I ain't really
I ain't really like playing on it to go
like this this [ __ ] just really just
feelings in my hands hmm it was a
feelings in my hands it should feel
quick too like this should just
within like a
year or two span you should just fell
into my hand so you had no like you
weren't you weren't making records
or were you always kind of making songs
did you feel like it kind of just
happened quick no in high school in high
school like my senior year that's when I
really just
got only this when I started putting
[ __ ] out like on YouTube and SoundCloud
and that is that that's how this is how
I create a buzz like within my city but
like I already had a name within like my
city
prior to like other than rapping like
you know what I'm saying like they just
knew me anyway but so senior year I mean
started rapping it just you know what
I'm saying just feel all into place yeah
and that's how uh when the dog Reach Out
I thought uh I got a lot I got locked up
by senior year
I think my senior in high school yeah no
it was after I graduated in fact yeah
well first of all shout out to you for
graduating yeah yeah I got out of there
yeah
not a lot of people uh get the diploma
so salute to you so he just reached out
you got locked up it was really my
auntie uh is married to his uncle like
she just told she's like just just talk
to him I don't really know exactly what
she said but I just know when I got out
he had reached out to me boom we got in
the car we chopped it up and everything
then it was y'all were locked in yeah
yeah we've been locked in but it's like
on the music level basically yeah yeah
on the music though hey we gotta stop
the interview man to tell you about our
good Folks at Blue chew baby that's
right make sure you go to bluetooth.com
uh and use the promo code bootleg yeah
because what happens at bluechoo.com is
you get the same active ingredients as
Viagra and Cialis but it's delivered
right to your door in a discreet package
no doctor's appointments involved fellas
yo it's getting cold as [ __ ] and you got
that dick you're trying to lay on a
lovely lady consensually of course all
right you might as well make sure you
show up to the party with all the
[ __ ] HGH uh you know uh
performance enhancing uh situations you
could have you really just need to pop a
single blue shoe and you're [ __ ] out
there man you're gonna have the hardest
[ __ ] you've ever had in your life
alright so listen go to Bluetooth
and uh use the promo code bootleg
because you get your first month for
free so go to bluetooth.com promo code
bootleg you get a whole month for free
try it out
okay try it out with that promo code
bootleg and don't forget they just
dropped their mint flavored chewable
which is the same active ingredient as
Levitra that's right so that means it's
a little bit more pep in your step you
go to the mint you go to Old School
Bluetooth whatever it is you're gonna be
[ __ ] bud for sure you're gonna wake
up in the morning with the hardest [ __ ]
you've ever had in your life all right
I promise that's Cyrus he just takes him
and jerks off in his bedroom
he's got Bluetooth Fridays at his house
everyone's out there working Cyrus the
producer he eats a blue Chute he turns
the surround sound on he's got the
[ __ ] PornHub going and he's just
beating his dick like it stole something
anyway bluetooth.com promo code bootleg
and you get a free month of blue chew
right now going to sign up and [ __ ]
help us out because you know what I'm
saying we trying to get this money too
all right bluetooth.com promo code
bootleg let's get back to the interview
would you say that like he taught you
a lot about just recording or writing
records or like did he like because
Dolph has such a nice like I feel like
his hook games are just so underrated
like his really his hooks were crazy bro
really he just
he let everybody do them yeah you know
like him like try to like touch nobody
work or tell him matter how to do
nothing like he just you know what I'm
saying just did everybody beat him
no I never you never just suggest me
nothing like that yeah yeah
um what obviously besides the music
um
are you dipping your foot into any other
sort of entrepreneurial [ __ ] opening
this businesses or real estate or
anything like that
yeah I always got my hands in some but I
won't be going to be like the face of it
I don't be wanting to be the one to take
credit for it right so I just stay
behind and closed doors right silent
investor yeah for sure that's smart like
that's why I can't nobody figure me out
without would you ever Act
yeah for sure have you have you thought
about doing that yeah this one that's
what I'm finna do really
when I get done with this with this
little rap [ __ ] I mean what does that
mean
like when you're done with the like
you're gonna retire eventually
yeah was that the goal because you know
some guys are rapping I'm gonna be
rapping when I'm
40 and [ __ ] Bro not not me right I'm
straight well how do you straight now
like financially but I don't like if I
mean I saw how much you paid for your
chain yeah I think you're doing all
right uh no how old are you right now
25. yes I mean that's you got 15 years
before you hit 40. yeah that's what I'm
saying I mean look man now let's just
put out King's disease three and Nas is
Like 50. so
you know you could do this [ __ ] out
that's crazy yeah you could do I mean
you I mean look as long but
some people just really passionate
passionate through it like I got a
passion for it but half of that [ __ ]
slick left you know what I'm saying I
miss a fake ass industry man the rap
game is super weird I don't [ __ ] with
them you know what it is
what all right you're very besides being
passionate about making music what is
what would you say is the other thing
you're most passionate about as if video
games is it [ __ ] movies is it
like you have a random collection of
[ __ ] at your house that you like like
what are you into
cars cars
yeah how many whips you got 12 12.
Jesus what's your insurance bill month
it's just so hot it's
like
damn near 50.
just for insurance
wait 50 000 a month yeah cause I got
other cars like
online insurance is not my cause like my
family like oh see yeah everyone Dukes
right you know what I'm saying like this
on my Jesus
what's your first of all what's the most
what's what's like your crown jewel your
car like the one that's like the one
like my favorite car your favorite
damn
I mean you have 12 so I'm sure
or the most expensive
I don't know I don't know which one of
my favorite it depends on like well what
color you have are you talking like you
got like like you got a [ __ ]
just name just name some [ __ ] and I'll
let you know if I got it do you have a
Lamborghini yes wow
do you have a Bentley
no choice yeah I got two Rolls Royce two
rolls royces why two just curious
why not stop at one
I just want to show them I can do it
again but who who do you want to show
that to
you whoever want to see it whoever got
something to say are they the same car
they like calling ins or what what is it
cutting in the done okay okay yeah do
you have a Tesla
so yeah so do I
yeah you just ain't physically got it
have you paid it in full though I put a
hundred dollars down all right well
still though you paid it in full um I
didn't know that you were able to do
that um
you know that's a Ponzi scheme right it
might be this [ __ ] Elon tells
everybody have you seen one like in
person like no
have you yeah where at here in L.A I
mean you're famous so you get the you
get the end right here
huh how was the uh it's hot it made me
want it more it's like a Lego block no I
I want it I just what happens is he
takes everybody's money and then he does
a bunch of other [ __ ] with it and then
you wait five years for the car to drop
and he's he's like thanks for the uh
it's how he it's how he like raises
funds
hey do you think do you think elon's
[ __ ] up Twitter
I don't know what's going on with it
like I've been seeing some [ __ ] like RP
Twitter what they talking about
like a thousand employees quit walked
out uh there's only like 200 employees
left they're saying that you know what's
[ __ ] up is that you could buy the blue
check now yeah that [ __ ] is so whack
yeah it is because I like I'm like
scrolling and I'll see like my friend
with like 60 followers now he's verified
I'm like bro you're a [ __ ] nobody
it's kind of like buying a fake Rolex
but then the social media version it's
like yeah you got a blue check but
you're paying eight dollars a month for
it and you live at your mom's house
I know you can pay for uh eight bucks a
month
you're gonna have to start you just put
some folks on game everybody in here get
verified right now
hey but even if you have to check
already yeah you got to start paying for
it right
I think I think so
yeah
I don't know about that you had to
maintain your your check I meant elon's
[ __ ] out here I mean you gave him
money for a truck that doesn't even
[ __ ] exist so you know that's nah
that [ __ ] is this
[ __ ] exists I mean he had like
four of them yeah I like I could get my
money back that's true hey give me that
and they're gonna give me that how much
was it
mine was like 1 118. you got the fully
load it yeah yeah with the uh ATV and oh
you got the ATV with it yeah the little
camera [ __ ] whatever it is it just look
cool bro this is all it is I want in
like 2029 when you finally get it I'll
hit you up and see how it is ain't gonna
be that long you might get yours in
2029. you're at the top of the list
because you passed your [ __ ] out yeah uh
do you play video games
I do but if I do I'm playing this [ __ ]
for like 20 minutes I can't yeah
what do you play even if I do got time I
just get bored quick yeah
I play [ __ ]
man
Call of Duty 2K that [ __ ] sometime you
know
that's making me mad Madden's been so
trash for so long are you uh are you a
Titans fan
I know it's like Nashville's not close
to Memphis but or I mean I know it's the
same state right
so would you say you're a Titan's fan
well who's your team now
the books oh Brady Bunch
now did you just become a bucks fan
because Tom Brady's there
I see it the Brady Bunch oh yeah yeah so
you're one of those guys huh yeah I want
to know yeah you got a [ __ ] football
team in your home state you're like I
like where top where's Tom Brady at
what what's your I mean obviously you're
a Tampa Bay Tampa Bay Tampa Bay they
[ __ ] with you in the bay yeah of Tampa
it's a good spot I used to live there
for real oh yeah say pink St Pete is
wild man it's a good place man
yeah you're obviously a Grizzlies fan
right
yeah fog one
okay so who do you really [ __ ] with yeah
now the way you just said that what I'm
so cool so whatever what other team do
you like
I don't like no other team like okay
who's your favorite player that's not on
the Grizzlies
easy money
sniper Katie yeah yeah is he tapped in
slow Reaper yeah yeah I feel like he uh
he's a pretty hardcore hip-hop head no
he's a real [ __ ] yeah
you guys uh text DM
I'm gonna be on uh audit yeah I let him
do him let him do me hey what up y'all
we gotta stop the interview real quick
to tell you about our folks at hardean
Las Vegas you see them right there you
know I mean shout out to hard D Man
shout out to everybody over there it's
the uh illest dispensary in the world
number one they got the craziest
selection of weed you'll ever go to when
you're in Las Vegas there's only one
place to go that's Hardy and you pull up
you say hey I heard about this place on
the bootleg cat podcast and they're
gonna get you hooked up with some
[ __ ] weed all right so go to Jardin
Las Vegas right now if you're in the
city of uh sin or you're going make sure
you uh you know put it put together a
little hour off to the side to make sure
you go get your nice [ __ ] Harding bag
full of uh just a premium weed all right
and not only that you got to shoot them
a follow Harding underscore Las Vegas
I'm gonna shout them out though because
Harding smells the best the dispensary
is just it's not only the best
dispensary in the world it's the best
smelling dispensary in the world and
look now the bootleg kit podcast smells
like Jardin because I have the hardine
signature candle you could have one too
you could go to [ __ ] Hardy in Las
Vegas just saying also make sure you
follow them online Harding underscore
Las Vegas that is important you have to
follow them because there's some
[ __ ] accounts out there we
appreciate hard Dean when you're in
Vegas pull up go get you some smoke go
get you some edibles go get you some
[ __ ] carts whatever it is they got it
and they got it at the highest quality
it's the only place I'm smoking from
that's Hardy in Las Vegas let's get back
to the interview
I like Katie because he's the kind of
guy he'll DM you if if you say some wild
[ __ ] to him like Andrew scholes my homie
he's a comedian he says some [ __ ] about
him online and this will DM them
like what he says I'm like in the
comments
yeah but then he I hit shows I say hey
yo look at what what uh Katie said he's
bro you just DM me so I'm like say that
[ __ ] to my face type [ __ ] if you see me
like bro you're a billionaire Katie get
all [ __ ]
I'd be willing to do this [ __ ] sometime
so I'd be like hey I ain't the one I I
get your IP address little bro yeah
people don't even know about that how do
you get someone's IP address
you have a [ __ ] Tech Team
just send the Twitter I don't know you
know that might be if if you ever did
retire from rapping you can start a
YouTube channel where you just pull up
on internet gang bangers on the keyboard
gangsters houses and just surprise them
not even do nothing just surprises nah
do you like pay attention to comments
and [ __ ] do you let that [ __ ] like get
to you or do you just like is it out of
sight out of mind type [ __ ]
I'm human bro like I ain't gonna say get
to me but
I only I don't I don't know I'm just I
don't play this [ __ ] I don't let nobody
just say anything I ain't gonna I might
not say nothing but I'm gonna take heed
to it like yeah I might screenshot what
you said like screenshot your picture or
something like you know what I'm saying
other than it I ain't gonna say nothing
to you yeah I feel like people who say
like oh the comments don't bother me
it's like even if you don't think they
bother you subconsciously you kind of
take that [ __ ] in yeah yeah
like you might you might not like let
people know what [ __ ] with you but like
come on anytime someone says I ain't
gonna say like it no it's not what I'm
saying but like you said you take note
of it
to it for sure yeah what's the wildest
[ __ ] like uh like just someone's like
said some wild [ __ ] to you like is it in
the DMS do they hit you with some crazy
[ __ ] is it just talking [ __ ] about music
like what is it
to be
you're DMV I'm trying to see like with
my comments yeah
they say all type of [ __ ] um
well you see what Drake did he he uh
someone talked [ __ ] and he uh DM the
dude's girl
he sliding and he found the guy's
profile
but he found it I ain't like that no
more yeah so you would you would in the
past you might do that
I would do that
just hit it like yo [ __ ] you I'm a [ __ ]
your chick yeah it's me that's great
yeah do you make sure they know that you
[ __ ] their girl
I'll make sure they know
I ain't I ain't talked to like Billy
like that I don't it's just good enough
for you to know that I [ __ ] the haters
girl yeah
what are your DMs looking like these
days though in general like bro I just
had sweetie on here and she was talking
about how she'd be getting all these
[ __ ] dick pics in her DM like
strangers sent her pictures of dicks all
day long do you get like crazy group of
[ __ ] in your in your DMs
this this part of the reason why I had
to like stop shaking my [ __ ] like right
I used to get voice voice messages and
everything like
like
I don't know something wrong with these
[ __ ] bro super wrong
I don't know bro something wrong
something has to be something with the
old drinking or something yeah I don't
know I think for anybody to like go out
of their way to send naked pictures of
themselves to somebody that they've
never met before is it's you have to
have something's wrong with it you gotta
be saying the the
the freakiest gross as [ __ ] like
um
what's the gross of [ __ ] to you
nah I ain't even see it cause I ain't
it's this
fairy price her and her husband probably
slid into your DMs you just didn't see
it probably did yeah I'm probably about
two now because
um any any tour [ __ ] coming up for you
but whenever I do it I'm gonna do it
after I
yeah yeah that's fair will it be another
pre uh compilation because the first one
was fire
I don't know yeah
I don't know what about you are you
trying to put your CEO hat on in sign
artists
um not right now I'm still learning yeah
eventually though yeah after when I'm
doing rapping
which will be 40. so 15 years
it might be 35 it might be 32. I read 30
[ __ ]
I just want to get enough money where
you'd be like [ __ ] this I'm gonna play
Madden all day and pull up on no I'm
still not interested gonna play Man all
day well if you retire from rapping like
you know you got to fill your time I'm
gonna learn how to golf golf rich [ __ ]
sport
dude
we'll learn how to go hey you know how
to swing oh I just don't know how to I
don't know the rules
yeah golf uh I don't have the patience
for that [ __ ] man you know who's really
good at that [ __ ] that was Schoolboy Q
from TDE yeah yeah he's like a playlist
yeah he's a playable character in the uh
in the new Tiger Woods game that was
hard really good oh yeah yeah
damn I ain't even know they made a game
yeah you never played the golf game
that [ __ ] gas
he got a nice place to go it's fun
do you remember
um you know wait you never played Tiger
Woods like oh 506 like
man when they had that [ __ ] going I just
know who he is and the fight you ever
play The Fight Night games yeah don't
make them no more they don't make them
no more yeah I know about them I'm like
why is it like this everybody's just on
[ __ ] UFC and you know what's crazy if
they make a new Fight Night game I
guarantee
Jake Paul will be on the cover
Maybe
he might be on the game
they'll sell them more who else they
gonna put on the [ __ ] cover they
can't afford Floyd
Floyd's gonna try to crack him upside it
has something crazy it's gonna be Jake
Paul's down Mega in the morning whoever
they get gonna text they is better take
this
you play the UFC [ __ ]
yeah I just don't like this submission
[ __ ] bro yeah I like like real street
fighting like me and my boys be playing
we'll be like like no grabbing no
submission we just
just basically fine so when you play UFC
with your boys do y'all have a rule no
submissions
remind me to never play video games with
you is she weak damn I yeah that's like
like you in the hood and you you getting
your ass beat but at the end you
maneuver your way out of something you
just
lock this [ __ ] head and arms up this
[ __ ] hollering y'all like this you won
the street man nah we don't do that
where we from no submission listen no
submission you get into a fight in the
street and somebody ends up putting you
on an arm bar on the [ __ ] floor they
win the fight
[ __ ]
it's a street fight someone's probably
getting shot for sure but you know I
don't know yeah it's definitely yeah
yeah that's one thing you got to be
careful these days because everybody and
their mom be [ __ ] training MMA I'll
be telling people like you just can't
just be picking fights with just
randomly telling you I'm like oh they're
training and lifting weights and that
[ __ ] don't mean nothing
hey we gotta stop the interview to tell
you about our family at odd sucks that's
right the most comfortable socks in the
[ __ ] world go to
oddsocksofficial.com right now use that
promo code bootleg and you'll save 20
off Christmas time is it coming and let
me tell you something their Black Friday
sale if you're watching this before
Black Friday you might be watching it
after Black Friday but if Black Friday
hasn't came yet just like Cyrus hasn't
came yet it's been a while he's on a
drought guess what oddsoxofficial.com
promo code bootleg 20 off plus whatever
the [ __ ] else is going on with their
Black Friday sale and let me tell you
they got some new licenses we got to
talk about boys
my particular favorites
one of the greatest shows of all time
they got the Beavis and butt heads you
know what I mean and this is really a
big deal
The Big Lebowski that's right the
greatest movie to ever exist
and shout out to all you rappers and
people who be pouring your lean into
this [ __ ] some Mountain Dew Baja
Blast socks
Casino great [ __ ] movie you know what
I mean these are pretty fly Bubblicious
yeah that's right a little Bubblicious
and this is the big one
big deal here
we got Coca-Cola socks baby that's right
Coke's on board
Coke is on board yeah I mean we get to
put the coke hat on
this hat doesn't work for me does it
doesn't work for me anyway you could get
you this hat though hey Cyrus take a
Coke hat there you go go to
oddsoxofficial.com use the promo code
bootleg right now save 20 off and go
purge their website for Black Friday get
gifts for your family your [ __ ]
family will love you if you buy them the
most comfortable socks in the world it's
that simple or you could buy them some
[ __ ] [ __ ] socks you could go buy
him some garbage ass [ __ ] ethica or
some [ __ ] ass [ __ ] Nike socks
[ __ ] them get Odd Socks let's get back
to the interview do you uh do you work
out
yeah you do yeah I walk
[ __ ] excess walk that's that's all you
do yeah damn I don't know if that's
working out let's be honest
I mean it's something so I I I he said I
want
is is is people in the world that's you
know
certain amount of pounds so
they can't just get up and just you know
move around but fat people walking
but walking can be like a the only
exercise that they can actually do to
you know what I'm saying get them a
boost or give them motivation super
clear we're talking about something like
so it's an exercise really obese people
yeah now you are noticeably small and
skinny oh Slim So in theory
could run yeah but why run what I'm
running from just to get your heart rate
going
nah nah because I I don't like being out
of breath
hell I don't like being out of breath
you play basketball yeah yeah you'd be
out of breath they should be killing me
though yeah yeah oh yeah yeah yeah
you're out of shape I know I'm out of
shape yeah I tell them all the time
trust me I know anytime I call I
probably called the most timeouts when
we play full court you ever puke because
you're so out of breath that's happened
to me nah yeah nah I know when to stop I
know my limb no sit my ass what position
do you play
what basketball yeah [ __ ] where would I
need me I know how to do everything
I feel like you'd be the kind of player
who just you just stay I stay back on
defense yeah yeah you're not playing any
of the events you go ahead I'm playing
but I stay back I ain't gotta I ain't
gotta get back offense sometimes this
[ __ ] is tired you're just stand in the
corner and yeah it's tired yeah
offensive hell yeah no defense is what
makes you tired
all right telling you
um all right well uh do we have any idea
when the full album is coming
I told you early early next year so
first quarter
before March yeah maybe maybe
not uh 5l why not 4-0 because it's five
songs or what do we do no I haven't
heard I mean
this is me this is what I represent yeah
and it's I look at it like
five is more than four so
let's do it that way these are these are
facts yeah we're gonna switch it up
five is more than four and walking is an
exercise sure both are facts big effects
yeah
all right
do you have your own weed strain yet I
feel like this sort of thing should have
happened nah I'm glad you asked that
you've seen a a pack with a Glock
anything and [ __ ] cap is there fake key
Glock weed yeah I've seen some what yeah
it probably got some it's your fully
okay
[Laughter]
they got like your face on the back
yeah not my face like my chain or
something like that keep like OG or some
[ __ ]
nah they know I don't like those you
like that what are you saying
what would you like to smoke
I like indicas I like starting hybrids
but I'm a little [ __ ] yeah yeah you
like the the super exotic [ __ ] yeah yeah
sometimes though the exotic shoes I love
OG but I'm old
I mean you know you just kind of know
what you're getting no there's sometimes
Skittle plusher Fruity Pebbles
and it's you know it's a cute [ __ ]
bag and it's like yeah it's got colors
and [ __ ] but you know I know if I smoke
some good OG I'm gonna be high out of my
[ __ ] brain so you know I just want to
get high I think most people are so
worried like you know when you're
selling packs and [ __ ] [ __ ] so
they'll open the bag how's the nose
nobody asks how does it smoke yeah
because really you got you gotta smell
it sometimes too sure yeah because you
don't want it to smell like like you say
[ __ ] little packages like I gotta
smell this [ __ ] yeah well you know they
sell book hat look I gotta like you
gotta crack that blood over and smell
that [ __ ] well they sell the bootleg
weed bags now
yeah you go to the [ __ ] liquor store
and get like a hundred you can go to the
corner store in Memphis that's what I
mean you could put any kind of [ __ ]
in a cookies bag nowadays
they could put OG in it hey
one of my favorite projects that Dolph
did was with Berner
you got a good relationship with Burton
uh nah not really I just I just been in
studio a couple times with them with
Dolphin yeah I ain't just got no
relationship yeah I'm about to say he'd
be the guy to talk to to get the
official straight up key lock [ __ ] is it
is
yeah he's on his way to being a
billionaire which is crazy
would you say me too hey I said Hey
listen man I see it you know what I'm
saying
now outside of music
I had a filthy rich on the show we were
talking about rap hustling he was like
man there's so many different ways you
can monetize
being
like he's filthy rich but how like what
are some of the things that you kind of
capitalize off the most when it comes to
getting a bag that's off of more things
than just when you release an album
I said are you doing features I know you
don't do a lot of features so
the crazy thing is
I don't even
like half the town even charge for
features bro right I just threw it off
the screen like um like
like if you guys like I I just I'd be
willing everybody to win [ __ ] you know
what I'm saying [ __ ] you gotta obviously
[ __ ] with the song [ __ ] with the artist
exactly the movement like if I gotta go
out my boundaries and out of my land
hell yeah I'm gonna charge you ain't
none against you I'm it's business I'm
gonna charge you but other than that no
I'm just gonna Show Low somebody
random's watching this and they got a
[ __ ] ton of money and they want you on
their album what's the what's the ticket
it's a terrible song Some just random
let's say drug dealer in Toledo Ohio and
he's like man I want to be a rapper I
got this shitty song all my friends say
it's good I want to put key Glock on it
he sends you the song it's dog [ __ ] but
he's got a bag how bad how big does the
bag have to be for you to hop on the dog
[ __ ] song
of course it sounds like I ain't about
the money bro it's about your brand the
person is like super that's what you got
going on yeah he's just got money
outside the studio like what's your
story like you know what I'm saying like
what's up what's what no so if he if if
if he's a 100 grand for a terrible
record would you hop on it it's a
terrible song
and nobody will probably ever hear it
which is positive because it sucks it's
it's another thing like would you take
the 100k
I ain't I ain't gonna say I win but
sometimes like it depends on the
situation I might and I might not like
real time you know what song I [ __ ] with
the song you did on Simba's album hot
that shit's super hard for sure he was
performing that [ __ ] with Jordan Lucas
and uh yeah that shit's fire ain't gonna
lie at first
I told I told my team I was like
I was like bro I can't I can't I can't I
can't rap on this I like I don't hear
myself on it but
I I played on that [ __ ] about a
week
and I just figured out a flow and I went
with it and that [ __ ] worked out
yeah yeah yeah now that's dope I feel
like sometimes you gotta step a little
bit outside of your comfort zone you
know yeah yeah why not man yeah yeah
um all right so go get the uh the new
project
you got a five pack out there right now
I don't know I'll run up the new Dolph
single fire
that's that joint that sampled man
salute to Dolph Long Live Dolph man
um new album first quarter
uh you're gonna be putting out uh
walking instructional exercise videos on
YouTube soon
pretty soon you're gonna be lighter on
finances because you're going to lose to
me in a ping pong battle huh
I had to interview Lamar Odom
why you got a ping pong table no I was
gonna find one goddamn listen don't [ __ ]
with me matter of fact yeah we got one
at the spot hell yeah we got one I'm
there pull up I'm there I'll take some
money off you um I don't wanna look
whatever like this random white dude
with the camera he's probably really
good I don't want no smoke with him
but you I'll take I'll take your money
you can't Sub in nobody he gonna be
fishing
he looks like he's gonna be gonna be
fishing while we playing ping pong while
I'm kicking your ass
he's gonna be doing something I'll tell
you that
um well [ __ ] man I appreciate you
pulling up bro I know you don't do a lot
of interviews and I appreciate your time
um it's good to see you man it's good to
see you in High Spirits yeah and uh [ __ ]
long lived off man key Glock appreciate
you brother so my boy